quest'anno si organizzato una bellissima
e grandissima caccia al tesoro regali
aspettativa verso in realtà iscriviti al
canale per non perdere neanche un video
ad ogni indizio troverai anche un
piccolo regalino che diventerà sempre
più grande fino ad arrivare agli immensi
gigantesco ma cosa dico fantasmagorico
regalo alla fine del percorso ma risentì
ma se per natale stir e galassi una
pinzetta e come renzetti un pettine
ma sì quelle cazzate che piacciono a te
no nel cominciare da capo scegli tu
regalo guarda fai tu scegli tu quello
che vuoi
adesso ragione però una cosa devi
rimanere sotto i due euro all'ora
certo perché sei una bambina
intelligente all'incisione neanche li
sicure
io ho 4 anni fa mi era sfuggito ecco il
bello di fare il compleanno natale vero
tesoro allora queste da parte di nonna
per il compleanno
questa parte di papa per natale questo è
mio perito compleanno e queste da parte
ben servita per natale oggi lo zio
ernesto per il compleanno i vicini per
natale natale compleanno natale per il
compleanno e questo invece per natale
ed ecco il tuo regalo di compleanno e
natale insieme piccolo il pacchetto mai
grande la sorpresa vivrai ma ora che la
vita si va e magica pensa si attacca
pure al frigo ecco la busta per la
nostra marina
siamo tutti voi soltanto i soldi notti
sicure cadavere altro ma così almeno
siamo contenti noi sei contenta puntero
mamma ma dov'è la busta ma che è sta
roba
lo so che volevi soldi ma io da madre
devo insegnarti a staccarvi dalle cose
materiali e acute riddick e sentimenti
con quello del cibo come sono astemia
sub dai aprilo allora visto che so che
piace tanto l'arte che ho regalato un
bel libro di storia dell'arte un
ingresso è illimitata tutti i musei
della città sia grazie bellissimo visto
che so che sei un appassionata d'arte è
enorme che belli ma si sa ma sono
orecchini sono regimi ma ora che
artistici è sia io non ho il buco ma
vabbè ma te lo fai quante storie che
tira noste appassionata di make up
un regalo che ti lascerà a bocca
[Applauso]
[Musica]
e questo il regalo per la nostra
appassionata che lei cup ma sono dei
calzini sono caldissimi vedrai ti
piaceranno tantissimo
[Musica]